good morning hick it's Tuesday so I
wrote all of these novels but I haven't
published a new novel in 6 years and
counting and I don't know when or if I
will publish one again but I am writing
and today I want to talk about what I'm
writing and why so one thing you might
not know about me is that technically I
am retired I retired in November of 2017
I just published my novel Turtles all
the way down and we'd gone on this
lovely but grueling tour and I was back
home looking in a drawer when all at
once my balance failed I fell to the
ground started vomiting was hospitalized
and eventually diagnosed with a disease
called labyrinthitis now labyrinthitis
is a lovely name for a disease and full
credit to the people who came up with it
but as an experience not recommended
like I lay in bed for weeks feeling
dizzy and disoriented and I couldn't
read or look at a screen all I had was
my thoughts and one of my thoughts was I
should retire like aside from the fact
that I couldn't turn my head without
vomiting I'd been absurdly fortunate in
my life I'd sold over 30 million books
and I had plenty of money and YouTube
views but for some reason I was still
chasing Book Sales and YouTube views and
money I just wanted more and more and
more I was kind of like smog from The
Hobbit I was sort of demented with the
Mania of owning things as Walt Witman
memorably put it and then I felt like I
kind of worked my way into the misery of
this labyrinthitis all for like money
and fame that I didn't need and that
wouldn't really make my life better so I
decided to retire for me retirement has
meant that I don't obsess over becoming
more rich or famous or more viewed or
whatever instead try to focus my
definition of work on passion and impact
like over the Last 5 Years our community
has raised over $40 million to build the
maternal center of excellence in sier
Leon which by the way is coming along
great and just in the last year nerd
Feria has helped make literally hundreds
of millions of dollars of impact in the
cost of TB tests and treatment and I
don't think I would have been able to
work so much on those projects if I
hadn't been retired so in a lot of ways
it's worked out also for me retirement
didn't mean that I stopped writing it
just meant that maybe I stopped writing
would people expect me to write instead
I wrote this weird and personal
non-fiction book called The anthropos
Scene reviewed which did end up finding
a broad audience but not nearly as broad
as my novels which is good because post
labyrinthitis me just can't handle that
level of attention and pressure that
came with publishing novels for me like
I do realize that these are the first
worldest of first world problems but
like having SNL sketches made about your
books or having movie adaptations made
of them uh is is is lovely and
interesting in a lot of ways but I I can
tell you that the the time in my life
when I was close to the center of us pop
culture was not a happy time in my life
like I really craved Fame and attention
but it it turns out that it didn't make
me happy it kind of made me really
really anxious so yeah I don't want to
do that again I'm still writing and I'm
writing fiction like eagle-eyed viewers
will know about the semi secet live
streams I sometimes do where I read the
stories I'm working on but mostly over
the last couple years I've been writing
somewhat obsessive ly about tuberculosis
which is exactly what I want to be
writing about like for me writing about
tuberculosis has been a way into trying
to understand both historical and
contemporary inequities like how did we
end up living in a world where 1.6
million people die every year of a
disease that most people in the rich
World never worry or think about that
didn't just happen it resulted from all
these historical forces and weird quirks
of tuberculosis itself and writing about
that has been tremendously fulfilling
for me I am aware that there's not like
a massive audience of people out there
waiting for a new book about
tuberculosis I I just don't care that
much I'm writing about what I want to be
writing about I'm writing about what I'm
passionate about and in a lot of ways
that takes me all the way back to 2001
and 2002 when I was 23 years old and
writing about exactly what I wanted to
write about which became the novel
Looking for Alaska I don't know if I'll
ever publish another novel ironically
even though they're made up novels feel
much more vulnerable and terrifying to
me but I am writing and I love writing
and I will have a next book hopefully
someday soon Hank I'll see you on Friday